what's going on guys this is Rob and in
the last video when we covered the
return of world breaker Hulk I mentioned
that I never really knew whatever
happened to scar he just seemed to kind
of disappear a lot of the guys said that
he returned in gamma flight and so we're
going to cover that here right this is
the return of scar in Marvel Comics now
one of the things that I do want to
specify is that in Jerry Dugan's Hulk
vol 3 that one of the things we found
out was that that really scar had like
faced off against doc Samson and it
actually been deep powered so he just
kind of lived in Paris for a while and
just kind of hunted and hunted in the
wilderness this is the return of scar in
terms of him being like the Incredible
Hulk type character that we know right
so that's why we're doing this and not
the other one but what this does is this
initially picks up with gamma flight
seemingly coming directly out of the
immortal Hulk so for those of guys who
aren't really familiar with that the
immortal Hulk was the name of the
Incredible Hulk run that was done by by
Al Ewing and what he actually
established there was a big change with
the Hulk Mythos that in years past you
just had Bruce Banner who turned into
the Incredible Hulk and that was
basically it what Al Ewing did is he
introduced something called The Green
Door which was basically that anybody
who had in some capacity been infected
with gamma radiation right even just a
single drop of it that whenever they die
they would encounter a green door which
would be their way to come back to life
basically but the Green Door was all
kind of part and parcel to what was
called the one below all which was quite
literally the answer to the question
what happens when the one above all
hulks out we have that video series down
in the description it's amazing it was
like this enormous Revelation at the end
that the one below all was basically the
Hulk Persona of the one above all it was
kind of nuts
it was pretty wild but the thing about
this is that the gamma flight team was
by and large and still is a kind of
unofficial team in the sense that they
were initially put together in response
to Carol Danvers who was leading Alpha
flight at the time trying to figure out
what had happened to The Incredible Hulk
when he just van finished one day and so
gamma flight basically sort of formed
over the course of immortal Hulk which
leads us to this so where the Incredible
Hulk had largely just taken off that
gamma flight is composed of some
ridiculously Heavy Hitters one of whom
is probably the single most underrated
character in Marvel Comics The absorbing
man Crusher Creole this guy can absorb
and turn into any material in existence
like literally adamantium the whole nine
yards if he can touch it he can turn
into it it's crazy how capable this guy
is I mean this guy used to go toe-to-toe
with a juggernaut back in the day in
Marvel Comics if that gives you any
indication but the thing about this is
that gamma flight for the most part is
kind of operating as what is in effect a
sort of Hulk Rescue Team to a degree so
for those of you guys who are really old
school in terms of Marvel Comics
remember the way that X Factor was
introduced under Bob Layton and then
Walter and Louise Simonson back in the
1980s that's what this is right it's
almost like kind of The X Factor of the
Incredible Hulk comics in some ways but
the idea behind this whole cool thing is
that they end up coming across what is
an effect a kind of Rampage that's
taking place out there and in fact it's
really the news that they ultimately
hear about it right it's taking place in
Austin with just like this giant crazy
looking thing that's like a giant
monster now of course gamma flight
responds because their Charter is one
half to kind of contain and control
various gamma irradiated threats that
exist out there their Charter isn't even
fully fleshed out here but the other
part of it is that they're always on the
hunt for like anything that can deal
with gamma radiation there could be like
a gamma irradiated being gone awry right
so like in the same way the X-Men deal
with like mutants they kind of go nuts
and use their powers for nefarious
purposes gamma flight is similar in that
way but of course this leads them to
traveling to Austin to figure out what's
going on literally by way of
teleportation and they're immediately
attacked by this thing which keeps on
growing you know keeps on throwing
things out by saying they're like it's
not going to go back that it's not going
to go back to like Green Spring right we
don't know exactly what Green Spring is
but one of the cool things one of the
crazy things that goes on in this fight
is that Crusher creel had previously
been given a piece of secondary
adamantium by Titania Titania is
basically his girlfriend and she kind of
they've been like on-again off-again
lovers in Marvel Comics for years
they're like the most dysfunctional
couple ever right so like every couple
from every reality TV show that's ever
been made it's basically them but the
secondary adamantium that he has while
it's not as capable as true adamantium
which is what's bonded to Wolverine's
skeleton what it does do is it makes him
almost Unstoppable in relation to like
this girl who's just tearing everything
up but what it does do is it allows uh
Crusher creel and even gamma flight
especially led by doc Samson to kind of
talk her down and when that happens she
literally starts to realize that they're
not with Greenspring and so once that
happens she reveals her name as being
Dion but then of course they're met by
the arrival of what is a person from
Greenspring and this comes in the form
of Scar and literally his presence
scares the crap out of her now we are
going to get an explanation of like how
scar came back and all that kind of
stuff and why he's got these mandibles
on his head right it looks kind of wild
he looks like a predator and it's kind
of it's kind of nuts it does look cool
though I'm not gonna lie but something
that I do want to point out here is that
scar is well known to the world as a
whole and even to like gamma flight
themselves now they ultimately end up
engaging in a Fool's errand right like
literally Samson just kind of walks over
to scar tries to have a conversation
with him and Scar makes it his last one
I mean that's literally what we're
talking about here it is scar this guy's
kind of just Next Level this dude I mean
here's here's the thing about scarlet
and people people don't understand
there's the reason why people are so
angry about Scar and the She-Hulk TV
show because he looks like he drinks
vegetable powder mixed with coconut
water wears air walks and like meditates
in the morning like that version of Scar
is trash scar is supposed to be just
this Beast of a character right just
this just demon of a character in Marvel
Comics I mean that's literally what he
is man this guy this dude's a one-man
Army he's a wrecking machine right and
so gamma flight has no chance here they
literally just get crushed by by Scar
now they are able able to kind of force
him off to a degree it is kind of funny
because for the most part they shouldn't
be able to but ultimately the team is
just kind of like teleported away or at
least most of them are the only ones who
aren't teleported away in time because
literally gamma flights running on a
shoestring budget so their teleportation
system basically crashes the ones who
are left behind are like Titania and Doc
neither one of which is going to be able
to take on scar right I mean he'll beat
these guys to death and be home in time
for corn flakes that's literally what
we're talking about here right but of
course once the system is basically
rebooted by the absorbing man who
absorbs technology and then just like
resets the system right like literally
gives it the juice it needs in order to
basically send everybody else in but the
thing about it is that in the midst of
this great big huge fight you end up
having the federal government responding
now that's one of the things that I do
want to specify here right there is a
character that we will kind of see
return to a degree named General fordian
when it came to the AL Ewing Incredible
Hulk Mythos General fordian was
introduced to us as The hoax specific
villain that was really more predicated
and kind of the evolution of Thunderbolt
Ross to a degree they're two distinctly
different characters but where
Thunderbolt Ross was the guy who was
after the Incredible Hulk for personal
reasons General fordian was to a degree
but it was also trying to find a way to
secure gamma radiation and then
weaponize it for the military so we had
much bigger aspirations and really even
applications in terms of his Pursuit for
the Incredible Hulk but the overall goal
here or the overall point here is that
of course General 14 Was Defeated right
I mean that guy was taken out he was
basically killed right more or less left
for dead and then in turn the federal
government still has its Hulkbuster
systems and so by and large when the
federal government shows up I mean it's
scar right like it doesn't matter like
he still trashes them it's just one of
those things where scars like look man
I'll beat you within an inch of your
life and the only reason why it'll take
the extra step and kill you outright is
because I'm having a good day but I woke
up the Sun was shining the birds were
chirping and I decided to spare your
life but if I had woken up this morning
and the sky was cloudy oh well then my
friend I would have sent you to meet
your maker that's literally how scar
works man it's just one of the coolest
things
right this is one of the coolest things
but ultimately because of all this
pandemonium and all this chaos what we
end up doing is switching over to a
quote unquote undisclosed location which
is basically the headquarters of project
Greenspring and what we end up finding
out here is that the person that is
heading up the entirety of project
Greenspring which by the way over the
course of this I may end up referring to
it as project green screen uh just be
aware of that I may make that mistake it
actually turns out to be Emil Blonsky
also known as Abomination so that's cool
because we basically get to see his
character return more so than that what
he's doing is he's actually removing
pieces of his skin and they're using
that to graft gamma radiation to
different people now we'll see the end
results of that because one of the
things that happens is that Crusher
Creole tries to teleport them out or at
least teleport gamma flight away and
when he does he actually ends up
teleporting them to the Future instead
and when they arrive there it's just
like this landscape full of these gamma
irradiated creatures which is really
kind of wild of course gamma flight
fights them off to a degree and then
based basically makes their way to what
is in effect a safe house but the thing
about this is that as they get in there
they find these construction workers who
are working on things but they're like
these gamma irradiated monsters and so
that's when Dion starts to come clean
and talk about the nature of the green
spring project and the whole idea behind
it is that it was literally grafting
gamma radiation to people now it was
initially billed as a kind of
improvement to an individual person it
started out with military application
which was basically like we can make
soldiers faster stronger more capable on
the battlefield kind of like a Captain
America Super Soldier type situation but
what Dion ended up finding out and what
seems to have come to ahead here and the
relatively near future is that what's
actually happening is that with Emile
Blonsky you know Abomination being the
one to spearhead all this that they're
actually applying gamma irradiated
tapeworms to people in effect it takes
them over and it turns that really would
turn the world into like a whole just a
huge Place full of gamma irradiated
zombies all of which seem to be
operating according to the whims and
wants of abomination now we don't
explicitly find out if that's the case
because this like depiction of these
individuals who are gamma irradiated
zombies that's about as extensive as it
gets now one of the things to know is
that Dion does not really come forward
with the information that Emil Blonsky
is the one running everything and in
fact the only reason we know is because
Al Ewing told us gamma flight doesn't
even know that's the case and even Dion
herself seems to be holding that
information back but what she also says
is once she learned the truth about what
was going on that this was initially
built as a military thing but in reality
it's just a desire to acquire a massive
amount of power she ultimately fled
right she literally took off hence the
reason why everything was going nuts in
Austin and why scar showed up and
everything that led us to here but what
ends up going on here is that back in
kind of like the present day you've
basically got the other half of gamma
flight right like literally Charlene
McGowan who's just kind of like their
scientific head she's basically trying
to to find a way to bring them back they
don't know that they're in the future
right they're just trying to find a way
to teleport them back to lock onto their
signal but as gamma flight makes their
way through like this kind of future
Wasteland to a degree they end up coming
across what is basically the body of
General fordian right like the body of
what is actually Dion's Father which
again is kind of a big Revelation hence
the reason she was all you know she was
brought on board in the first place but
of course at this point they don't fully
know what's going on and even with
General 40 and himself he kind of seems
to be communicating of his own volition
which is kind of weird because his
head's twisted around on his head or
like on his on his shoulders it's a 180
degree twist his neck's broken right so
it's kind of weird how in the world this
guy's able to talk but of course before
they really even get any information
whatsoever or any Revelation at all
they're ultimately teleported back so
this future depiction of what the world
looks like is less about information
gathering outside of what it was that
Dion told us and it's really more
designed to kind of show the end result
of how this entire project will unfold
and so because gamma flight realizes
what will actually happen if they don't
find a way to stop this what they end up
doing is basically traveling directly to
the base of Green Spring right literally
going to its location and being led
there by Dion herself and so one of the
things that I want to do is I want to
get into like the nature of Scar and how
it is that he got his powers because
this is an important distinction here so
first things first let's talk about
General fordian and Abomination so
Abomination has just kind of been dead
for a little while but what ended up
happening is that when he passed through
the Green Door Abomination was reborn in
the body of general fordian and so what
this did is it allowed Emile blonski to
take on his Abomination form but when he
transforms back into his human form he
turns into General fordian but what it
did is it gave him all the memories of
General fordian along with all of his
own experiences so one he's basically
this guy with all this military
experience hence the reason why he's
more intelligent and more capable than
he normally is because under normal
circum stances I mean let's just let's
just call it for what it is
abomination's kind of dumb I mean like
let's just say it like let's just let's
just call it right he's just kind of a
dumb lumbering Beast who's really
comparable and capable to The Incredible
Hulk and like that's basically it but
him having the memories and the
knowledge of General Freudian that's
what makes him so capable in the here
and now so that should answer the
question a lot of you guys probably have
which is why is abomination so smart all
of a sudden right why is he so capable
all of a sudden but the other part of
this is that seemingly ever since
General fordian had reappeared and
basically come back to life after his
death the reality is that it's just been
Abomination pretending to be him now if
you read Immortal Hulk you already knew
that right that was literally told To Us
by Al Ewing but for people who never
read Immortal Hulk that's kind of where
Abomination ended up returning but
because of the fact that he had the face
of General fordian then he's literally
in a base of people all of whom believe
that General fordian is following the
right idea it allowed Abomination to
kind of control all things behind the
scenes with no one being any the wiser
to the fact that Abomination was
controlling General fordian and so one
of the things that ended up happening
here is that by whatever Manner and
whatever means scar became part of the
equation now with him being de-powered
the idea here seems to be a desire to
regain his power to get back to where he
was before and so this is why he was
given a portion of abomination's Flesh
which basically allowed him to regain
his gamma radiation all the while being
unaware of the fact that he would
ultimately end up becoming an agent of
abomination even against his own will
right literally becoming a kind of
mindless servant and so once this was
proved to be successful the same project
was initiated with Dion as well as a
multitude of other people now for the
most part the kind of grand expansion
that Abomination or at least that we saw
in the future under Abomination that
hasn't happened yet most of these
soldiers who were like uh gamma
irradiated zombies to a degree they're
just operating inside the base right
they're just kind of there in this local
base and that's effectively it but the
realization of what it is that
Abomination is looking to achieve has to
ultimately be dealt with the big caveat
to this and the kicker to this is that
doc Samson starts talking about
something called the cathesis Ray which
is a ray that has the ability to split
people specifically in this instance
separating Emile Blonsky from General
General 14 right splitting the two in
half now it's also going to have a
secondary benefit later on down the line
but one of the things that goes on is
that once they make their way to the
base having been LED there by both Dion
as well as Rick Jones and Delray who we
haven't really talked about yet but like
that's the guy who's green and has like
a head sticking out of his shoulders
it's a whole crazy thing literally it
was two different people who were
ultimately merged that's essentially
what's going on here but ultimately like
between these two gamma flight is led
directly to the base of Greenspring and
so once they arrive on the scene things
basically kind of go the way you would
expect them to right like scar goes out
to kind of get his uh get his sort of
payback to a degree on gamma flight and
literally starts attacking the entirety
of the team leading a kind of army of
these gamma irradiated zombie type guys
with him right they just face off
against the forces of gamma flight what
is cool here about about scar is it is
interesting to see that his character
has a little more development the
downside here is that it's not the scar
we traditionally know now people who are
hardcore fans of scars somebody won't
like that right they're like I want to
see the version I love or I don't want
to see a version at all it's just a
different writer's interpretation on the
character of Scar but the reality is
that like even I'm kind of disappointed
that it's not like this super awesome
scar that we're normally familiar with
the guy is by all standards the
measurement a henchman right that's
basically what he is here now he is able
to hold his own against the entirety of
gamma flight and for the most part like
he kind of crushes this team to the
point that like they only really have
one option and that is basically Dion
talking directly to scar it's one of
these cool moments and I love the way
that Al Ewing did this because what she
basically reveals to him is that he's
ultimately being used that Abomination
doesn't actually care about scar even if
he's putting off this idea that like the
Incredible Hulk did you wrong and I can
basically make you I could make you
whole again and I did make you whole
right and we can kind of fix these
things and you can get the revenge on
your dad that you want and that kind of
a thing that Abomination doesn't
actually care about Scar the what
Abomination is doing is basically using
scar to achieve his own ends that's
really all that's happening here but
once that explanation is given to uh
given to scar by Dion then he ultimately
turn codes against Abomination and all
of his forces more so than that what
ends up happening is that once they get
to this giant ray gun that once they try
to turn it on it actually explodes like
it actually overloads and then just
blows up so now this thing is completely
and totally useless but fortunately for
us absorbing man who has now become a
plot device in the gamma flight story
ends up touching the machine and then
absorbing the gun into himself so now
like his hand is this cannon that fires
off this Ray this separates beings who
are imbued with gamma radiation and so
one of the things that he does is he
literally fires this thing off at the
Rick Jones Del Rey merger of sorts and
splits those two characters in half so
like they go back to their status quo
but with scar siding against uh
Abomination and actually joining the
forces of gamma flight he ends up taking
the fight directly to uh to Abomination
himself which is kind of a cool thing
because in the midst of this giant
explosion one of the things that it had
also done is it basically nullified the
gamma irradiated zombie type guys they
end up spitting out these tapeworms and
just going back to their normal cells so
just kind of a way to sort of wrap
things up but this is where things get
cool because one of the things to know
about abomination right and it's one of
the things that's really unappreciated
about his character while Abomination is
normally dumb he's ridiculously powerful
I mean it's crazy how strong and capable
Abomination is and in fact it's really
kind of an amazing moment here because
what you have right to give you guys
perspective here this is like the
Incredible Hulk having all the strengths
he traditionally has but have having the
battle experience of Thunderbolt Ross
that's basically what this is imagine
what kind of what that Incredible Hulk
would look like that's a version of The
Incredible Hulk and that's actually a
story that I want to see this this is a
version of The Incredible Hulk that
would basically be able to use military
strategy to kill the Marvel Universe
it'd be pretty cool right it'd be pretty
awesome like if Captain America became
the Hulk that's literally what this is
right so that's how Abominations are is
is operating right now and so that's the
reason why if this were any other
circumstance where you've got absorbing
man Crusher Creole with this giant ray
gun for an arm that would split uh
Abomination and General fordian in half
that like Abomination would largely just
be defeated and the story would end like
that then instead he actually used this
battle strategy to overtake absorbing
man and then in turn start firing his
weapon off at other people not only that
once absorbing man is dealt with you
then have scar who jumps into The Fray
and again Abomination crushes scar like
he literally just snaps his arm just
like that and that's one of the cool
things right this is one of those
moments when people will either agree
with it or they will disagree with it I
actually agree with it but I agree with
this idea because Abomination is by and
large under any normal circumstance
comparable to SCAR or even stronger just
because of the fact that Abomination has
gone toe-to-toe with the Incredible Hulk
under some pretty heavy-handed
circumstances and so once you have this
version of abomination with a military
strategy of of General Freudian that
includes martial arts training and all
that kind of stuff right all those
different things so it's no Small Wonder
that he's able to overtake pretty much
everybody here what's also crazy is that
like Dion steps in trying to take out
Abomination and he literally just starts
absorbing her right like quite literally
just like like inhaling her it's kind of
nuts how that whole thing goes but given
the nature of her powers and the fact
that she is kind of intangible to a
degree she basically ends up overtaking
kind of swarming into Abomination which
allows the momentary distraction where
kind of shock can be fired at
Abomination just long enough to sort of
kind of send them out of the equation
now what's really kind of weird about
this and this is the thing that I don't
really agree with is that Abominations
sort of retreating just feels arbitrary
right it just kind of feels arbitrary
and weird he had them all on the ropes I
mean he had them all on the ropes scar
was out of the equation gamma flight was
getting crapped on I mean he had these
guys for the most part taken care of but
then when when Charlene McGowan just
fires off this laser shot at him which
is enough to injure him that he in turn
is like okay now it's time for me to go
right I mean it's weird it's like the
old uh the old Superman TV show from way
back in the day right they're shooting
bullets at him bullets are bouncing off
of his chest so like they throw the gun
at him and what does he do he Ducks
right it's that kind of thing right it's
weird it's just it seems a little
unnecessary here and so ultimately he
ends up basically taking off and then
gamma flight kind of continues on his
Charter of doing whatever it is that
it's supposed to be doing which isn't
fully defined because honestly gamma
flight was just a temporary storyline
this is literally a five issue
miniseries so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end they
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace